yeah I like this is James Bond right
let's eat you see us dude
correct hey hey how you doing I'm two
Chinese I'm Brad nice to meet you
brother they meet you well right how's
it going today very good today I have
something special for you
I have diamond in keys vodka and then
I'm gonna create a ten thousand dollar
martini
we use our premium vodka from France
that we import and it's our own special
boutique vodka that we produce here once
that's important we grab our diamonds we
put them into these small carafes and we
let them infuse for about a week and
that gives the essence of diamonds would
you like to smell damage before I guess
on where you're gonna taste something
shortly too as well these are the
diamonds that we use routine of them you
have the Diamonds with you I have them
ready to go now Shh boogers right there
boy is the diamonds $10,000 in the drink
you just throw that in for free that is
correct
what happens if I swallow the diamond
what do I have to do that you have to
wait Fanny poop I'm not even like really
a serious drinker but I gotta have this
experience
yeah you cannot buy this anywhere
acceptable clues lounge
this is the diamond infused vodka and
then now this is what we call martini on
the rocks gotcha that is now a $10,000
martini
tastes good - chains okay
very strong I have one more special
surprise for you - chains
you thought the $10,000 martini was
spectacular but here we do the hundred
thousand dollar martini
that's a hundred thousand dollar diamond
sitting right there
check that out this is a real done right
on the money
look at ya then the cut you're drinking
is a princess cup and it's GOI approved
one hundred thousand dollar diamond just
over 5 carats rim the truth I really
can't distinguish the taste in the vodka
but I can't distinguish the style and
some of the flavor that it has to offer
would I ever do it I can't say that I
will will I do it for a female we all
[ __ ] up
ha ha ha I got my dog shall we yeah good
music brother yeah right let him get out
cuz he loved his coming pocket that's
this way when he bought it on a barbecue
or not these [ __ ] love it he probably
can handle this right yeah this is
$100,000 drink yeah so he definitely got
the money on me little bro what's that
man without the don't [ __ ] with me bro
man I was this I hear about this hundred
thousand dollar dream bro you a
connoisseur I can type it in haste cause
you have a specific taste yes we deal
know if it tastes like diamonds yeah
let's see
what it is on that's a diamond cocktail
right there I'm a martini boy thanks
Sean I like that I tell you the lawyer
they tell you like a Rolex it's me a
little bit of Rolly Rolly decides to
change
I sold eight of these lights and I've
sold them to mainly wedding
anniversaries it doesn't Devon that
romantic [ __ ] that this Detroit Clara do
my stepmother you say you didn't hate it
either
I do then so I'll tell you eight more
days put it on 2 Chainz taking apart my
car gonna be the mouse and like now's my
man Brad you know like when the cameras
was off I told him like straight up I
was gonna take like you know R&B singer
and then just get him to drop like a
cubic zirconia and then because no one
has a diamond tester and who the [ __ ]
he's gonna pay $100,000 for a martini he
did have a dope restaurant and he had an
accent for them [ __ ]
I [ __ ] she bore double salut